hello guys welcome back to big mood
we're going to start right off with
a a sponsor zola is an online
wedding planning service for all of you
brides to be
out there are you ever engaged and you
just like don't know how to make your
wedding happen
that happened to me i'm like wow cool a
ring oh my god i have to make an event
happen
how does that even how do where do we do
that
well zola makes it very easy uh you can
find wedding vendors in your area
you explore save the dates and
invitations you create a free wedding
website you build your registry it's
basically a wedding planner without the
cost of a wedding planner
so go to zola.com big mood today and use
promo code save 50 that's save 500 to
get 50
off your save the dates you also get
free personalized paper samples before
you're purchased
that's zola.com big mood promo code save
50. yeah let's get on with the show i
i think it's a missed opportunity that
when people send out save the dates they
don't call it std so you can just
give it to people you know i just gave
you my std
i'm going to give hundreds of people
stds well that's uh very fitting for the
topic of this oh
um today i asked the girls
if we could talk about crystalia and his
um
re-emergence from under the rock that he
crawled how long has it been since that
whole scandal broke out uh that was like
in june i think
so it's been almost eight months that he
just completely disappeared
um like nine months yeah almost yeah
um what do you guys know about the
situation because i
i know that i was a kind of a fan of his
but were you guys fans of him i
read did you know anything about what
happened i was not really a big fan of
his but
um i mean he was all right i mean i
eminem has him in his music video so
whatever but um yeah i did delve into uh
into the the heat um you caught up with
the
yeah the the juice um
so he was like giving girls alcohol like
young young girls alcohol and like
getting them super drunk and then
having sex with them
creepy ass texts but then like all the
texts were talking about
all these people's experiences were that
like he would continuously bring them
drinks and more drinks and more drinks
and like
talk about having sex with them well he
was also really
like the texts and the dms at least
because like i reported on jk news so i
did read
through a lot of them and he was just
really creep
creepy but blunt of like hey so do you
want to come to my room like hey do you
want to suck my dick like
yeah like what do you want to do like
and he was just pretty much using his
like
like that power dynamic thing where he's
a celebrity
and then if you're a fan of his then
like come [ __ ] me
yeah pretty much and so without any like
yeah human party just using them as like
objects and then also the fact that
a lot of these women were saying that or
i don't know if it was a lot but at
least a few were saying that they were
underage
and that he just didn't really bother to
check or that he knew they were underage
okay so there's obviously a lot of uh no
one really knows what's
going on you don't hear about a bunch of
drinks so
there was some there was a one thing in
a hotel room where he had alcohol
available for girls there and then
there's also been a lot of like
speculation on that he's a pedo or
something like
that i was a fan of his so i looked into
this a lot more than i think most people
do
because i yeah you were a big fan i was
a big fan and um
so i did see him in person once um i
went to whitney taping
that's pretty cool yeah long ago i used
to watch that show i mean that's kind of
where i knew him from but anyway
he was kind of like not really a factor
until his podcast came out where i think
that's where he actually got a lot of
his fame was from that because
let's be honest his stand-up is not very
good i've only seen
one your hair is just so nice today i
can't stop it
i like it it's really really tangled
just shiny
is gina you're getting off course here
but i've only seen one
and it was like my favorite segment
that's the only thing i know about him
it was
it doesn't even matter the drunk girl
the drunk girls was that was kind of
funny yeah so i mean like
from from those bits he got a lot of
female fans like
if you look at me i'm a blueprint of his
fan base i think and a lot of people
in comedy know that a lot of his fans
were girls
um what i liked about his material on
the podcast was a lot of comedy usually
consists of like self-deprecation
and it's always like oh just like really
kind of like dark things where you try
to make it funny but like chris is all
of his stuff was just like
no i'm the richest guy alive i'm the
youngest guy alive like i'm so [ __ ]
buff like they're shooting a movie on my
[ __ ] back like
and i felt like it was kind of funny to
hear someone actually
like make comedy in a way where it was
like i feel good about myself you know
like so that's what the
big deal that's kind of like why yeah
the big dick energy but it was very
browy and it's not
great comedy that should be respected
and i know he's not very respected in
the comedy world i get it is he not
no i don't think so i really don't think
he is i think he
oh he was everyone has their niche yeah
so his name is it's it's like
trashy like she's like cook respected in
the comedy world uh
some people like him i think they liked
him a little bit and then all of a
sudden the whole world turned on him
somehow
oh you got too popular
it's like where they like especially
comedians like when they see someone who
kind of doesn't really deserve it
because their comedy's not that good but
then like the public eats it up because
it's like trash comedy
it's like jim carrey you know like he
goes like wild like on top
and then just like everyone just started
hating on him oh really
i thought that the comedy style just
shifted from like jim carrey style to
like
oh it did that's true too yeah what
people wanted
yeah people got you know sick of it and
it became more hacky right yeah so like
for
for me like if i'm gonna say who my
actual favorite comedians are right now
would be tim dillon and dave chappelle
so that's the type of comedy i like but
for some reason i also liked crystalia
style comedy
has never left my list yeah he just can
do no wrong
been my one of my favorites forever my
favorite was uh freaking
louis ck and he got cancelled too for
very similar things
so the dick the pulling the dick out in
masturbation thing
that is one of the accusations against
chris
was that um so i i took some notes
because i i
have like i actually did i went back and
reread like what did the news actually
say what were the allegations
there was one where this girl who was an
actress she was 26 at the time this was
in 2011
she said that her insta mutuals they
were out in west hollywood they went
to go eat dinner he was like oh hey can
you give me a ride home she didn't
really know him that well but she marked
him as like a safe guy because he's just
like mutual friend or whatever she's so
she's like yeah sure i'll take you home
so he gets in the car and he like he
starts acting kind of like
so you know what are we going to do now
kind of thing and she's just like
you know like i'm just giving you a ride
home but then he whips his dick out oh
no and
starts like masturbating she gets out of
the car
he like finishes
apparently these are all allegations
right and then so
i don't know what happened but i guess
somehow she got him out of the car and
then
left you know and then so it was just
very weird like very creepy
deviant sexual behavior but the kind
that like louis ck did where like there
was no one actually attacked or raped or
anything but it's like that rape of the
eyes
the fear of like i don't know what this
guy's going to do next
yeah what could happen is very scary
because he's a powerful celebrity at
that
has that ever happened to any of you
guys like a dude just whipping out his
dick
yeah in front of you and jerk jerking
off when you didn't want it to happen
yeah i remember in high school
whoa i almost got some smackdown in the
corner like walking home from school
um i was walking home from school with
my girl jasmine and we always split at
this corner but we all stand that corner
and talk a little bit first
and then um at the corner there's a stop
sign and
like shh i was facing the stop sign her
back was face towards me
and i remember talking to her and
realizing i had like one earbud on and i
realized huh
that car's been stopped at that stop
sign for a while and then my music
like the song dies down i hear oh
no then i was like and your friend
didn't hear this and then like she
i i don't she was talking you know and
then i looked behind her and the guy in
the truck was like this asian guy that
was just jacking off
and i remember he was kind of in his own
little space though right
yeah yeah you invaded his space you
walked up the hill
yeah he made eye contact with me and
then i remember the first thing i
thought was
why is it soft well yeah he was drunk
enough it was soft and i was like
i've actually seen him yeah i've seen
that because he was like in a truck and
i was like or like he was in a car i was
standing somehow that i can actually see
in there
what if it was hard wow that's sad
that's really sad and i told my
girlfriend jasmine like jasmine
walk away right now and want to make
sure that you walk away safely because
she had to walk past his car
it was gross yeah some other thing
happened to me too i was in like
fourth grade i think oh no or fifth
grade
and i was walking to my friend's house
who lived near
our school and i would always go to her
house after school
but the and usually i walk with her but
this one particular time i had to stay
late
to do something and so she took off
without me so then i had to
go to her house and i walked past
um this one home where this dude was
like on
kind of like a flower bed ledge like
right up the romantic
right up against the house and i
remember
clearly like he was wearing these
basketball shorts and he asked me he was
like
hey excuse me do you know the time and
then because i had to watch so then i
look at the time and i tell him the time
and when i look over he had his dick
like out like through the pant leg of
his basketball shirt and he was like
slithering it like a snake and i was
i was [ __ ] he was dramatic i don't
know
it looked like that in my fourth grade
yeah like that's what i saw
it was probably moving up and down like
probably but to me it looked like it was
like that and i was just like
it turned into a molly basically in your
child's mind it turned into a monster
yeah so i went i ran the rest of the way
and i was crying the whole way
and i was just like my heart was
pounding i'm like holy [ __ ]
like it was intense i've never um
had a guy like masturbate in front of me
where i wasn't approved first
right but um when i lived in downtown
l.a and little tokyo which is very close
to skid row i did see a lot of homeless
dick
but i kind of give them a pass because
they're on drugs they're kind of crazy
or
you know like they're already so you get
on like kind of oh my god
whoa like in hollywood like not on
purpose
not on purpose uh i was in hollywood and
yeah
a houseless man um
urinating on the wall and i didn't know
he was doing that until i
walked by on hollywood boulevard into
his live stream
it like splashed on me yeah and then i
was like oh it's not raining
oh oh ah where did it hit you
oh my [ __ ] that's scary too because like
i remember when i was living in downtown
too they had to like
they had to spray the streets with i
don't know some sort of uh disinfectant
bleach or just coming because there's
just like hep c outbreaks and stuff so
you never like yeah
getting peed on by him a houseless
person is quite scary
just in the skid row area but anyway so
other stuff
that allegations against chris were um
there was
like stuff um i guess talking about
teenage girls things but everything i've
seen like
when i get to the end of that road it's
like oh he realized that they were 16
and then he pulled back and
stopped right so i didn't see any
clear evidence that he was pursuing
underage girls there was probably a lot
of like younger 19
20 year old like very he was in his 30s
questionable because like it's socially
acceptable right especially with
celebrities
to me i find it creepy to go for girls
that are
10 years or junior or 15 years younger
than you i just don't they're just
they're
living out what they didn't get when
they were 20 or
19 right because he's not a
conventionally
attractive guy yeah so then now he has a
celebrity and now he gets [ __ ] thrown
at him so many youtuber guys were like
that
like they just blew up in gaming and
they're nerdy dudes
but like they had this huge following
and very scandalous things
yeah very scandalous it's like one of
those things where like am i shocked no
am i disappointed yeah am i surprised no
you know
it's but as far as illegal
um i don't think i personally don't
believe he did anything illegal
right um morally creepy creepy yeah
morally
wrong yes because there was like
exposures those
are illegal activities like exposing
yourself to someone
when they didn't concern is i feel like
that's illegal so i don't know
but it appears he's avoiding any charges
for anything like that
um because maybe the girls felt like
well you know i went to his hotel room
and
maybe they're maybe they're blaming
themselves so they didn't target
someone you have to have a lot of
evidence it takes a long time there's a
lot of courts
it's like it's a process like do you
want to involve yourself in that long of
a process no that's why most people
don't
charge someone without enough evidence
to yeah
prosecute them that's true so like if
you look at someone like marilyn manson
who was like actually abusing
yeah uh the people that he was with and
you know this the
i think the city is actually i heard
something about like he would ask people
like you want to see my girl's boobs but
that's about it really
what you didn't hear how he was
torturing people oh it was like bdsm but
like on the abusive scale where it
wasn't actually bdsm
and like yeah anymore girls up and keep
them from eating or talking to their
friends or
like this was all non-consensual yeah
according to
the women are saying a lot of women now
are saying damn it i love marilyn manson
yeah i know
um so so i think so i think uh the city
actually just is already
or the sheriff's department or somebody
like it's there's a there's a point to
where like the city or the state can
investigate can investigate you
regardless of if a victim
calls for it or not so like someone of
that level of like actual
you know illegal abusive behavior
obviously deserves to be charged
chris probably deserves maybe some sort
of fines or something but it seems like
he's not getting anything and that's
that's whatever oh yeah
a guy did flash us in a park one time
and
you're just sitting here thinking about
random dicks nobody it just reminded me
that
like um because cops were called this
thing because there was more than
just me there was like families and
stuff and so like um
the cop was like do you want to charge
him and basically nobody charged him
because it was just like a process yeah
sometimes it's like not worth it
yeah and then they have your like they
know who you are you become a target
yeah or like if you sue someone then all
of a sudden a lot of your own personal
information has to be revealed
true for whatever public data yeah so
i mean i get why they wouldn't and why
he should probably still deserve some
sort of
something but i think the backlash in
his career kind of getting
[ __ ] is is pretty good you know it's a
pretty good
matches the sentence thank you because
he's so publicly embarrassed you know he
yeah he he went in he came and
apologized and the apology basically
said like look i
realized that the celebrity and the sex
and all that it turned into an addiction
i was feeding emptiness with the
addiction i didn't realize
that because i was straightforward with
these girls
that it still was kind of a using type
of behavior i didn't realize how like
bad it was until
it became that bad like i didn't realize
how shitty i was being
until it blew up and then now i see that
my behavior was like shitty
sexual addicted behavior his his
video coming like coming back and
i don't know like me reading whether or
not it was genuine
it was like i don't know i felt like a
lot of it wasn't very genuine i think
he's still
in the middle of coping with the fact
that it's an addiction and also like not
really wanting to
believe that yeah he's kind of he
doesn't have control over his addictions
maybe
i felt that also it's as a man to have
to like sit there and make an apology
video like i get how that's
probably really difficult for someone
especially someone that built up an ego
and everything like true to have to do
that is very difficult
um and also something i discovered in
that apology video is that he was
actually still cheating on his fiancee
who
he has a baby with that part honestly
kind of hurt me more than
any of the rest of it because it was
like i would still be cheating till this
day if i hadn't yeah
so i i think you said that yeah i
figured like a guy a celebrity like that
like yeah he's gonna get famous he's
going to get a lot of [ __ ] or whatever
but then i'm like oh he found this girl
that now publicly he's saying
this is my fiance i'm in marion we're
going to have a baby i thought who was
this girl i was like wow how [ __ ]
amazing
yeah how lucky like and then how awesome
is she that like
she's so amazing that he's willing to
like forego the spoils of celebrity
to like now be a married man while he's
still very
very well young enough to get a [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] so i was just like wow this is
crazy like he's such a good family man
like
you know and then trying to find out he
was cheating on the whole
cake and eat it too yeah that was super
disappointing
for me that is disappointing because
that's more of a character flaw like you
have like the
addiction quality but then also the
character flaw of
or you know if not well i think that's
what the addiction
does to you though it like above all
else
the sex part of it like getting your fix
is above
every everything else so that is kind of
like the addiction part of it so like
you can be married to someone that has a
sex addiction and they love you they
love the kids
but then they're still gonna like try to
find ways to get that hit
until they actually fully deal with the
addiction so it's true i guess with
drugs though it's like
okay you may have lied to me and broken
that promise
but you didn't like cheat on me or like
you know we weren't disloyal to me with
a girl or whatever there's a different
form of that when it comes to there's
still a betrayal yeah
definitely there's still betrayal
because then they're they're like
stealing from you
to get money for their drugs or whatever
so yeah
with a sex addiction too because they
can bring home stds and yeah
like it involves your health yeah
so that's really unfortunate but um
i guess i i you know i took a well one
thing that i found was curious was that
when he did disappear none of his
friends
really stood up for him no one in there
people like disowned him
so i think there was definitely like he
had a reputation
of like i mean maybe the girls were
getting younger and younger like 18 19
they're like whoa chris what's up you
know like they saw
they saw that he was shitty with women
women were a commodity
and that's very unfortunate to find out
as a fan
and i think a lot of the women that are
in his fan base were kind of like oh wow
we feel
you know duped kind of in a way we're
like we we liked him and his personality
and we were a fan of him we
gave him that yeah but then it turns out
in real life he treated women like
like [ __ ] basically so that was um
very sucky yeah i guess to go through
you know and so when he comes back
when i saw him come back i was like a
little bit disappointed i was like man
i'm gonna have to
er my trust back yeah well it's gonna
make me laugh real good
it's not like i it's like that weird
thing where you're like
i know this person probably doesn't
deserve
to [ __ ] go to hell and like yeah have
everything stripped from
it you know so it's like you have to get
to a place where you're like okay well
now we you know
he deserves to be forgiven but like i
kind of don't want to but then like i
know he should be forgiven so it's like
a weird
feeling when you are a fan of someone
and then they do something and then you
have to be like
okay now i guess we have to process it
and let it go and let you live your life
so there's a weird
do you think like like when he jacks off
and he like
he he finishes does he get hungry
burns a lot of calories i would be
hungry
like i would want to eat like pretty
fast though right right right like
right away right but like something
fresh right yeah something that you
could just whip up in like 30 minutes or
less right well
ladies thank you for that transition
because i wasn't sure how i was going to
get the jacking off in hella fresh but
you guys did it for me get there um you
guys know what hella fresh is it's one
of those meal
uh delivery kits i told whole freshly
said yesterday hellofresh is actually my
favorite i've tried some other ones even
though hellofresh is one that sponsors
because i'm i'm lazy so i'm like i want
to keep
trying different ones hellofresh is
actually my favorite i can say that for
sure
it's convenient no contact delivery to
your doorstep for easy cooking
um i always get the one for like the
family and cook
extra yeah and then just that's the way
to do it yeah it makes your life so much
easier we can kind of meal prep but also
recipes that aren't the same boring like
turkey meatballs and rice you know like
you get to try new things that you
wouldn't have tried before because you
get recipe cards
which is pretty fun you know what's
really cool isaac has actually been
making
our most recent shipment because they
they give us like three meals
so isaac's already made two of them oh
my god yeah
yeah yeah well i mean casey and i are
there to help mainly casey it holds your
hand though
makes it easy yeah steve could do it
well that's saying something
that's saying something he did burn the
shepherd's pie but the other one all
right
that one was really good that was really
good you can easily change your delivery
days or food preferences you can skip a
week whenever you want to
um go to hellofresh.com
12 and use code big mood 12 for 12
free meals including free shipping again
go to hellofresh.com
big mood12 and use code bigmood12
for 12 free meals with the free shipping
um yeah so go try america's number one
meal kit
that food probably goes right through
you huh it goes right through you up oh
my god
right through you why are we so
disgusted i don't know our transitions
are fire
they're disgusting terrible go ahead
after you eat
the food goes right through you and you
gotta poop it out and you don't want to
go to bed and lay down with a dirty butt
and i am a big fan of one wipe poopies
you guys ever had those poopies where
you just keep wiping and just never stop
you're disgusting i just get in the bath
at that point
right and you just start crying um but
you don't have to worry about that
anymore because of hello tissue
yay hella tissy is a bidet and we all
know
that we are huge fans of bidets we
actually have one here
um so you've probably been pooping the
wrong way your whole life and have no
idea
the brand new hello tishi 3.0 modern
bidet attachment is here and it's
stylish eco-friendly easy to install
and affordable the best part about is
that you don't have to plug it into a
into a bed so yeah so anyone can have it
hello tissue 3.0 doesn't just cleanse
your butt with a precise stream of fresh
water
it also cleans itself before and after
it's used with a smart spray
automatic self-cleaning nozzle it
attaches to your existing toilet
requires no electricity or additional
plumbing
and it cuts toilet paper used by eighty
percent see
one wipe or just a little like one
square and just pat it dry
so the hell of tushy bidet practically
pays for itself in just a few months
plus every hello tissue bidet attachment
comes with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty
seriously after you guys like the bidet
life you just don't go back from that
it's hard to because then you feel dirty
after like when you're in a public
restroom that doesn't have one
exactly it's pretty gross no i wish it
was like japan here and just every
single toilet have it
japan's toilet goals
so now you can go to hellotushy.com big
mood to get 10
off plus free shipping this is a special
offer for our listeners go to
hellotishie.com
big mood for ten percent off plus free
shipping that's
hellotici.com slash big mood clean your
butt butt
clean your butt cleaning thanks gina for
that yeah
the secret is you have the water spray
up your butt like an enema
like you have to lose flush it out just
relax your butthole let it go in there
and then not only does it like clean it
in there but it also
helps whatever little heidi little small
poopies that are still in there
disgusting
disgusting i mean we talk with a doctor
before flushing your [ __ ] with water
why are your walls so sticky little
pieces of heidi's
it's healthily lubricated in there okay
anyways um don't really discuss
it i'm just picturing an [ __ ] with
[ __ ] and a bunch of water and i'm like i
don't know
i i don't know if that's medically
sounded because my visual was like an
intestine
well anyways moving on i when i was
going through
this topic prepping for this topic i
looked up sex addiction because i wanted
to get a little bit of a better
understanding because like we hear about
it all the time but like
unless you're actually going through it
or you know someone that's going through
it maybe you don't fully understand it
what i found interestingly enough was
that the american
psychiatric association does not
classify compulsive sexual behavior as a
diagnosable mental health disorder
it's not listed in the dsm but the world
health organization
does so it's weird like here in america
yeah the who
does listed as a mental health disorder
here in america we don't listen as a
mental health disorder i found that to
be
quite interesting and like you would
think addiction
in itself it would be the disorder
because like i
like you get addicted to your phones
like there's like yeah yeah yeah like a
dick even just the fact that it's a
compulsory yeah compulsive behavior that
it would still classify some sort of
mental disorder
why they don't i don't know for sure
um but it's because the people running
the american ones are
are sex addicts they're like insane a
disorder
i don't want to admit it no it's fine
it's not a practice any time
but is that a problem though the fact
that it's not listed as a mental health
disorder is it
is it because we make compulsive or
possibly unhealthy sexual behaviors
normalized like are we saying like oh no
that's not a disorder like it's fine to
[ __ ] watch
all day long it's fine too that's true
um have sex with thousands of people
it's fine like is there something
about our culture yeah for sure yeah
it's hard to say because if i try to
make an analogy with alcohol for example
um i think it would be in your ability
to stop doing it because
like for me i like to drink i could
drink a drink every day and
then stop like i don't have a prop a
problem with
shopping there's i could go years
without drinking at all yeah
you keep telling yourself that nikki go
ahead
i've actually had a full bar the whole
pandemic because it's i can't
i've noticed that you've stopped
drinking yeah i like don't if i'm not
going i have to do something
after i drink also i get drunk off of
one drink so i'm a really
cheap date but um but yeah i judge it by
like
you know i have some friends who had a
serious problem where
they couldn't stop like once they start
started they couldn't stop they would
wake up in the morning and want it
like they would think about it all the
time like i think it's like you don't
stop
thinking about it whereas like i only
really thought about drinking if i was
like oh we're going out to dinner later
like
i wanted to have good martinis you know
that's that was my didn't be cassidy
chemical addiction for you yeah or a
mental one either really
so with sex it's like i could love sex i
do love sex
but i don't think about it all the time
constantly and what am i gonna get my
next hit
you know whereas someone like i mean
chris is saying that for him it did run
his life like everything he did every
show he went to
all day long it was running his life so
like food okay like i yeah i did have an
eating disorder yeah and at one point in
my life
all i could think about were calories
and food and when my next meal was going
to be and how many calories there was
going to be
and for like two years like it was
that's all i could think about and every
and i would get really irritable if like
i
messed up somehow yeah so even if you
didn't have bulimia or anorexia you
still had an eating disorder
yeah what's the one orthorexia yeah
it's like we're obsessed with being
healthy as healthy as possible
like it stresses you out if you're if
you're gonna eat something like if you
take a bite of a cookie then you're
really stressed out but yeah
even though you're not like bulimic so
you're not starving or throwing up but
like
i would go to the gym for like five
hours if i had a bite of a cookie oh man
i need that disorder
she's like a lighter version a lighter
version of it don't glorify eating
disorders okay
lose weight lose weight because so much
stress
like you talk about the gym part oh you
could use it yeah yeah
i mean we could all go to the gym let's
be honest
but it's weird because why
don't these mental health professionals
agree
that this could become a mental health
disorder
they're stupid are they those i mean
these are your faces
maybe do you think maybe it's because it
hasn't affected people to the point
where they're like they're
dying or they're in danger yeah like
what classifies a disorder like stds are
like
pretty dangerous to people i mean in my
anxiety it doesn't
kill me but i live with anxiety and it's
still a disorder
like you're right yeah i don't know i
just found that to be very interesting
and i feel like more people need to
consider
like you know mental health professional
you need to
clarify why that's not considered a
mental health very odd
then like if it's not is drug addiction
considered
i i'm not sure or alcoholism but it
seems like
usually a lot of these i think addiction
and drug addiction would be classified
or maybe it's like a male run industry
this whole like mental health thing and
they're just like ah he's just [ __ ]
horny we're all horny
maybe if your body's not physically
dependent on it
that's true because you're not physical
but you i think they probably get
physically dependent on whatever rush of
dopamine
serotonin or whatever they wouldn't have
physical withdrawals though
you know like where you know if you are
addicted to opium or whatever
um yeah it's a chemical addiction yeah
or they don't shut down like anxiety
makes you shut down and can't do
anything
maybe well like i think that i think it
does like for example
like sex addiction or porn addiction
like there are
things that happen to you after you stop
oh
yeah i think it does affect your yeah
like your perspective your brain
psychologically yeah psychologically for
sure but i
but you know your body being physically
you know i'm going into physical
withdrawals or like being physically
dependent on it
yeah it's a weird gray area where it's
like you know you do these actions
that then give you surges of chemicals
like dopamine
then do you become reliant on those
surges
of dopamine from the actions that you're
taking in order to get them it's a
it's a really question because so like
so with dopamine it's like i get
we all get that from our phones that's
why social media is becoming an
addiction
we do get those spikes and dopamine from
like
likes and comments and whatever um or
what or just like being scrolling i
don't know what it is
really but um but it's not i don't think
that's considered
uh a disorder yet because no it doesn't
yeah they have
that's not there yeah i think we've yet
to
like cross over that hill and maybe
maybe they will
eventually get classified that way
because or maybe not
that the freaking lobbyists that have oh
yeah well they yeah
they're gonna be like money off of it
yeah true
how do we diagnose and then give them a
cure for it they can make patches like
nicotine patches but they're
social media patches yeah they give you
that brick
for a phone where there's like literally
nothing just like fake scroll
um but yeah so i did want to list out
because maybe people don't know like
am i addicted to sex or how do i know or
whatever so this is i did find
they listed out things behaviors and
attitudes may include inability to
contain sexual urges
detachment meaning that the sexual
activity does not emotionally satisfy
you
strong feelings of attractions to other
alongside continually being in love and
starting new romances
um so i guess that's the love addiction
part of the sex addiction but um
feelings of guilt and shame giving up
social work related recreational
activities
um so it's just a lot of things like
meeting up with sex workers cyber sex
practicing unsafe sex persistent use of
pornography multiple affairs multiple
sexual partners one night stands
compulsive masturbation so
that's got to be difficult i would say
to pick a line and say this is where
you've
crossed it right unless it's just i mean
if you can go to work
like chris he went to work he showed up
to every gig he had
uh he got married he had a kid he had a
relate he has a relationship his
relationship with his parents his
brother his you know he's
he's functioning in every area of his
life
but then also yeah chasing this
addiction
and like disturbing a lot of other
people's lives from it like his fans
that kind of got used and thrown away
so at what point do we give him a pass
and be like oh this is an addiction
i understand he has an addiction and i'm
willing to forgive him for that and at
what point is it like
not right it's just behavior that's
just shitty yeah that's that's a tough
question that's a great
philosophical question because like i
struggle with that and you know but it
seems like a lot of people especially
men like they'll give them pass
i don't know why i mean like louis uk
came back really fast did he oh
yeah i mean he's done he's functioning
in the community
did he come here he came he came
so so hard back
i did buy his new special i will say
yeah so i just had to see what it was
like
was it good yeah he actually it was a
lot of it was about
what he went through yeah i liked louis
i know me too yeah it's weird because i
i toe this line of like being a warrior
for women
because women are often victims of male
sex what he did was
wrong right true but it's like ah
yeah i don't know so that's another
question i have for you guys
do we need to hold
entertainers to a level of moral
perfection
do we expect entertainers who are
probably kind of [ __ ] up anyway
because why do you want to be an
entertainer
you know like are you attacking two days
yes i'm attacking
all of us right now i know everyone in
this room um just because she's quitting
to be a cpa
she's like why would you even want that
no no i'm just saying like
or 10k why do entertainers have to be
moral
standing sister i don't know i don't
guess that's a question like even if
like it was a regular dude i was dating
that trapped me in a room and started
masturbating or like i wasn't dating him
he's just a friend
like that i don't think that that i mean
that's not an entertainer i would still
hold them to the same same time no
that's what i mean
like that these people like so is it
okay to like let people like chris and
louis
come back because we're like well
they're [ __ ] entertainers
they're degenerates anyway kelly coming
back can we listen to r kelly are you
asking permission no i don't want
permission for that
that one was actually a minor no we're
right he was locking i mean that's along
the lines of what you're saying though
right where it's like do we take the
entertainer or like the art
for it like it's own thing we allow that
to exist can you separate the
artist right yeah that is a a really
great question
and also i think that everyone has their
own personal moral
line you know where um
you know i know a lot of girls women in
comedy that will never accept louis ck
back in
the space right well especially his own
victims probably well yeah
yeah but yeah um yeah i don't know yeah
it's really tough because
i mean i'm conflicted too because i
think about that but then also like if
you
think about like if you
brought in that idea and then you go
into like
well what about companies what about
like uh brands that we
we buy or that whatever that we endorse
like
we don't know every single practice
practices of everything they've done or
to get to where they are like we don't
know like the iphone that there's
children
exactly things like that we still use
these iphones or fast fashion
exactly right so then it's like well
[ __ ] like
where do you draw the line like how do
you how do you feel about all that
there's a ton of people out there that
do their due diligence they actually
research a lot of stuff and i'm like
more power to you max i don't know how
to do that i don't have the energy for
that but
like morally though like i would love to
can you ever be perfect
yeah all of the your daily activities
that you do
and who you support and what you support
and what you buy from where you spend
your money
yes i feel like have you guys ever seen
the good place
i watched a few seasons because there
was a few episodes but it got a little
dry for me so there's this one part that
really reminds me of what we're talking
about right now so the good place just a
quick recap it's like
uh it's a sitcom show where
they think that they're in heaven but
really they're in hell but they call it
the bad
place in the good place and so there's
this one part where they're trying to
find out
spoiler well that doesn't happen for
seasons into no that it happens in the
last season
i mean the first season at the end of
the first season okay sorry i spoiled it
but the point is the point that i'm
trying to get to there's still a lot
more shows i actually didn't get a lot
there's a lot more show after that okay
i had heard it before but sorry if i
spoiled it
but the point is um once they end up
getting to like the
accountants like when they're actually
tallying up your points when you're on
earth to see if you make it to the good
place or the bad place
everyone on earth for the past i don't
know how many years have been telling a
points or getting
negative points because of all these
things for example like oh now i own an
iphone
i get a negative a thousand points
because a child because of the child
labor
so it's just like no matter what we do
like way back in the day
um like centuries ago you know a guy
would pick
a flower for his mom like give his mom
flowers
and like you know he got it himself and
all this stuff and so he got plus points
but then today if you go to the grocery
store and get some flowers for your mom
you're gonna get
negative a ton of points because you
don't know like the labor that went into
that all the ethical
like right like people in the fields are
probably massively underpaid
taken advantage of and all so that's
that's why i brought it up because i was
just like yeah like where
what do how do we i think if you live in
the first world there's no way
you're not contributing to that like
even like we stand on the backs of the
people in the field yeah i mean just by
existing here living here and being our
culture and society has built it around
that where you can't function in it
without somehow contributing but i mean
we're not
purposely individually affecting
the lives of other people negatively
right so at least like
if we know about things we can make the
decision now oh as a consumer well i can
choose not to do that because whatever
whatever i'm just going to make my own
food now
i'm going to move out to the country
grow my own food i'm not going to have
an iphone i'm not going to you know you
can choose to
participate or not whereas someone like
chris he's choosing to masturbate in
front of a
woman in her own car so there's
obviously a difference in that type of
activity consent is always the thing and
i know in his apology he was like
um all of my acts were consensual
so but then you know with the
allegations there's some allegations
that don't like the exposure
yeah where he's kind of glossing over
like you know
if he was in his hotel room and he
called the manager to come up to fix his
ac but he was naked while he was in
there is that consensual i don't
know is that is that true i don't know
because i looked at that specific
allegation that the hotel itself
was like you know we we never got any
reports from any staff so we don't know
but you know
when it comes to a celebrity it's hard
to say if people are going to rat them
out or not they don't know if their own
job's going to be affected
that's true yeah there's a power dynamic
there that like
you're almost too scared to yeah and i
did have this other question i thought
um
is it easier to hold the moral high
ground
when you're not being constantly
bombarded with
the things that you would become
addicted to or that could potentially
turn you
into a bit of a deviant so like say gina
has like a
penchant for maybe she's curious about
eating people
maybe she wants to try what's the people
eater let's try a little piece of
someone's leg i mean
so if you got to go to a buffet every
weekend
and try pieces of human could it
potentially affect
you and turn you into an actual cannibal
to where then you would go and murder
people i mean like
there's some weird kind of deviant thing
that maybe all of us have
kind of sitting somewhere deep inside of
us but we're not given that
right on a platter on a daily basis to
say no no no no no
so like if we're given basically the
thing that we want like say i like money
and i want to go buy [ __ ] hermes bags
right
like what would i get to a point to
where i'm gonna start doing
like illegal things to make sure that i
can keep that money and then to keep
buying like so
well that's why there's all these [ __ ]
up scenarios with people in power like
people that have
like a lot of money i mean uh epstein
you know like all these
all these things are coming to light
because once you get to a certain point
where
you can have anything you want you want
you just get
weirder and weirder and then you don't
even know where normal yeah
so then like is that human nature to
like once you reach this level of too
much power
maybe we should find out if like we're
even able to create more humans right
you know
so i can so that i can eat more well
not that you know you're not going to
eat all right
move away from that and let's talk about
although you can eat the placenta
i heard that's healthy i don't know yeah
if you eat your own placenta no it it
helps your nails in your hair and stuff
right and how
does that only your own medically sound
advice but you know what is medically
sound
modern fertility thank you jess so
modern fertility
uh is a home fertility testing kit
and so this has actually been really
really really helpful for me personally
so once we got sponsored they sent us
over
home kids and i sent mine in i got my
results
and i was getting really worried because
i
you know casey and i have been trying
for so i took out my birth control two
years ago but
me like really been trying since like
september and i'm mexican so i'm like
i'm i'm why aren't you already married
yes you're born with five babies
exactly like whole life should be a
pregnancy right so i'm like how why am i
not pregnant yet and so i got worried
and so that's why i was just so grateful
for the european blood
yeah is it yeah yeah so then i got i was
really grateful that they were able to
send us a kit and
so i got my results turns out i'm normal
for my age yeah me too
so i'm like oh phew oh you got yours too
yeah i got mine back mine says normal
and everything and i was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me i have symptoms and i
wanted hormones to be the
damn reason it's not all right well uh
first of all before telling you how to
get this kid i do want to
mention that traditional testing with
your doctor can cost over
a thousand dollars but modern fertility
only costs 159
to get the same exact information all
you have to do
is do a simple finger prick and then
mail it in with a prepaid label and then
you'll get your personalized results
within 10 days also if you have an hsa
or
fsa you can use those dollars on modern
fertility
you'll get insight into how many eggs
you have like nicky hormone levels like
jazz
and other important fertility factors
like what i received as well
and so the results go deep into what
every hormone means and you can also
talk one-on-one with a fertility nurse
to review your results and options for
next steps
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 20
off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com
mood that means your test will cost 139
dollars instead of the hundreds or
thousands it could cost at a doctor's
office get 20
off your fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com
mood that's modern fertility.com
[Music]
pretty good and if you want to start
getting busy making those humans maybe
you want some nice sheets to lay on
yeah you're our next sponsor's brooklyn
and i broke linen sheets on yesterday oh
yeah the freshly washed ones
how's that feeling for you they feel
like butter yeah
the more you wash them too the better
they feel it's true they get softer
they do they're like the only sheets
that i've ever had that feel like a
hotel like it really
feels like that hotel yeah and it's the
only sheets i've had where they feel
better when you wash them too because
i've got some other sheets and i've
washed them probably about 15 times now
and they're starting to feel
like they're falling apart don't wash
your sheets gina
when i wash my brook linen sheets they
feel better wait how often do you guys
wash your sheets
every two weeks every two weeks but
there's only one person in my bed and so
i sleep for yeah
look at this i'm disgusting is this
weird because i i sleep for one week on
one side of my bed and then i sleep for
another guys
bed so brooklyn was started by rich and
vicky who also tried to find beautiful
home essentials that didn't cost an arm
and a leg and when they couldn't
they founded brick linen as the first
direct to consumer bedding company
they work directly with manufacturers to
make luxury available directly to you
without the luxury level markups
brooklyn has a variety of sheets colors
patterns and material i got like stripy
ones
it looks really good me too i got that
one yeah i got that oh wait no sorry
mine are like plaid fire
okay sorry i got the solid uh white and
the solid cream
boring okay they have over fifty
thousand five star reviews
just did two of them because she sleeps
on two different sides of the bag
and brooklyn is so much more than sheets
they're they almost they got comforters
they got pillows towels
oh towels are so soft what the hell can
we get towels
right i need towels we even have
loungewear okay
thanks bryce and more lounger
even though they got loungewear yeah go
check it out go to brooklyn.com and use
promo code
mood to get 25 off when you spend 100 or
more
plus free shipping that's b r o
l and enter promo code mood
to get 25 off when you spend 100 or more
plus free shipping
brooklyn.com and use promo code mood at
checkout
that's right that's a big discount
twenty-five percent it's a lot of
set the mood with the right sheets there
you
go
good job that took a while yeah i it was
like
that's what's happening too long
honestly okay back to
our topic of discussion because i got to
keep you [ __ ] in here
jess was a fan [ __ ] like she was a fan
that [ __ ] up
like star [ __ ] star [ __ ]
that's really have such strong opinions
against it because
uh i actually experienced it but anyway
she hadn't gotten blocked this could
have been her
true oh [ __ ] you could have been the
wife
no no i actually have a boner for his
brother magdalena oh
get your shot girl can you guys
[Music]
we've talked so much [ __ ] about his
brother at this point i think uh my
channel imagine he becomes your brother
my chances with matt are
you we're being pretty fair i think we
are no okay so my question again was um
do you guys think that if you are
bombarded with
easy access to your vices that you
would be addicted either perfect
or would you succumb to your addictions
i tested myself um i fostered kittens
and i was like
turns out i have some good willpower i
mean
that's not really what we're talking
about you said my vices
okay having lots of kittens is not a
vice think about [ __ ] think about
your own personal how cute
so think about your own personal advice
like what's something that you kind of
do that you're kind of like i don't
think i should do this
i know i forgot perfect because i'm
literally doing it every day
which is what my advice is to be able to
cross a sloth oh
a sloth that's just depression i know
yeah it's just depression no i don't
think i'm depressed
i don't think so i do i do think i might
you're a high functioning depressant
maybe i don't know who knows but
every day though if i don't have
something scheduled or like a commitment
that i have to do that's outside of
a commitment that i've made to myself
like for example if i tell myself like
oh tomorrow i'm going to do some yoga
outside of that because i won't do it i
will just
lay in bed that doesn't hurt anymore i
know i don't think our vices hurt
anybody
no it hurts it hurts my family oh they
want to spend time with me and then gina
is
sorry no yeah but like no yeah it hurts
because like sometimes
you know like well more recently i'm
like trying to peel away i'm like [ __ ]
you could do this [ __ ] and then so like
we
i've been trying to go hiking and stuff
but like you know with isaac i see him
growing up so quickly he's already 13
and like his whole childhood i'm like
there was so much more
that i could have done maybe you have
low iron maybe or something like
vitamin deficiencies i really think i
have a vitamin yeah somewhere that's
easily
figured out when i i when i tested low
on i think it was b12 and
and vitamin d i was low on d um
i i found out my birth control was
actually blocking my absorption
but um but anyway i loaded up on
supplements and also i changed my diet a
little bit
i used to have to take a nap at like 3
p.m every day like i was so
fatigued all day every day and then that
vitamin deficiency thing like turning
that around
i had so much more energy also like
going plant-based for a while
how do you test that there we go yeah if
i could go to your doctor
it yeah it was um how do they do a blood
test
literally you can go to like quest
diagnostics and just get blood it's the
easiest question
but i'm talking about vices though like
maybe you like to drink
a lot or something like maybe when you
drink then you start
cheating if you had constant access to
go out every weekend and cheat like you
know like at what point
do you feel like you're perfect and if
you have the opportunity to have
everything you could ever want served to
you do you think that you would be i
mean is it
yeah like my question is like is it easy
to stand on the moral high ground
because we don't have access to the
things
that we could go down the hole with is
or do we really feel like no there's
some people who even when they have
access to everything i think it brings
out
who you really are yeah i honestly just
think that money and power
bring out who you really are a lot of
people get money and power and they're
huge philanthropists and they start big
charities and they they give a lot
yeah because i i mean when i really try
to be honest with that situation
i don't know if there's a thing that i'm
like dying to do
like they're really the same so i that's
why i was trying to put myself in the
perspective of if i had those
knowing me i i don't think i would be
like we'd all be like travel addicts
yeah yeah there's like go to all the
beaches in the world yeah because i i
feel like those beaches
the reason why i bring this up though is
because i feel like a lot of men excuse
behavior like this like from lewis and
chris because they're like well if you
had access to all these women and if you
had access to all
like who would you you know you'd
probably they're living out of high
school fantasy
honestly they're just like they they
wanted all these things since they were
younger
they saw other people getting them and
then now finally when they're way older
they have all the money and power and
women are flocking to them
a feeling they've never had before like
and maybe they've always secretly craved
it
and so yeah i i can see how that would
affect someone's mental state i think it
all depends on
how you grew up how much of you were
fulfilled throughout your life like
yeah it's so hard for me to form an
opinion on this because i've never i
don't really have like an addictive i
can't relate
yeah yeah related to it not really an
addictive personality
well okay i do have another question and
it involves like the
celebrity or like the general public
versus
but yeah the general public versus the
celebrity and like when people come out
with their apology videos and all that
and then you know the fans have to
take it in and decide what we're going
to do with it accept it or not allow his
career to come back or not
do we stay mad at celebrities
because they're not necessarily having
these behavior
epiphanies on their own it's like they
got exposed and then now they're forced
to change that behavior so like chris if
he didn't get exposed
he said he would have probably continued
to con to do this
kind of sexual deviant behavior he would
have continued to cheat on his wife
is it harder to forgive him now because
we know that he was just forced into
this like oh
this behavior is not good and now i'm
embarrassed or
is it is it hard to forgive because of
that or or does it change the dynamic of
forgiveness at all
you had to hit rock bottom something bad
happened to you then you realize you're
wrong so which one is it
or what then you realize you had to
change oh man that's that's a tough one
it depends on what it is too
because like with bill cosby like 60
something women coming out and saying
they got drugged and raped the same
exact way it's a little harder to like
wrap your head around the like
forgiveness there because that caused
trauma
in so many women you know i think it's
about how many other lives you
affected in my personal opinion because
i think everyone's different when it
comes to
if how much of a fan they were how bad
they think their
celebrity [ __ ] up you know um how how
good they apologize you know i think
it's
everyone's got their own levels of what
they're willing to accept but
for me if it's like you personally
inflicted pain and trauma on
other people and other people's lives um
it's harder
to come back from that i think malicious
intent yeah like
yeah and taking advantage and i feel
differently
if instead of being exposed one day he
just got on his podcast and he was like
you know what guys
i've not been able to sleep i realize
that i've had
an addiction and i've been um treating
my fans like a commodity i've been
sleeping like if he
exposed himself would we forgive him
differently
that's better way better yeah so it's
better for you to just
be upfront with it confront it move past
it and be better and so like if
if chris would actually come out on his
own and actually
say like yeah like expose himself and
then
because that taking accountability is
the first step really is like
i don't even think he knew that he was
doing something wrong you know he did
either that's the hard part
that's true on this particular instance
yeah even when when there was no consent
given he whipped out his wiener
i don't know maybe he was drinking he
didn't realize he could also play it off
he says he doesn't drink
he doesn't drink apparently he doesn't
even have that there was a couple other
comedians that after this came out like
a couple other like got
almost like secondhand exposed because
like other comedians were also
had also done these things like whip
their dick out and
i don't know if that's just a thing in
that circle i've never had that happen
there was one story
with chris where another comedian said
that like he would
whip his dick out like just in front of
like if there's guys in the room and
girls like he would joke around with it
and be like oh here's my dick like kind
of like a locker room thing that turned
into like
too much and now there's also women in
the room so like what the [ __ ] but like
i can see it like the guys when they get
together they they create
kind of like they will kind of create
that toxic kind of environment that's
crosses lines and but then if you're in
it you kind of maybe don't
realize how bad or toxic it is yeah
also i mean they're [ __ ] comics
they're degenerate so it's like
some are better than others but it's
weird it's a weird
environment right and especially for
women it's very difficult for them to be
in it
as it is and then to be exposed to that
kind of sucks too
[Music]
in a room full of people yeah but like
just one one-on-one locked in the car
right yeah that's really scary yeah
that's where i think if you're
if you are suffering an addiction if
you're if you're able to live with
yourself after doing something like that
you must be able to justify it in your
head
somehow yeah because like when i was on
drugs like i would justify
whatever action i had to do i did coke
and went to church once you know i
justify
like in my head reasons why it's okay
right i mean the higher you are the
closer to god so yeah i mean
i get it
i'd be a great drug addict if i can
justify like that jesus christ
that's pretty good that's pretty
specific
yeah but the whole forgiveness thing
though like i think if if he
with his actions i guess it's just
really how
he's probably gonna gain the respect of
of his
own audience of the public it's just
like how are you gonna conduct yourself
moving forward
yeah was he able to save his
relationship
i think he's still with his fiance as
far as i know
like no one in the no one's announced
that they're not together as far as i
know
so what's the public reaction to this
video how were the comments how did they
feel about him obviously
positive well okay well when i was i was
looking through them
well if you look at comments on his
channel right and then you go to reddit
like sometimes there's a different story
because like
we don't filter you we don't know what's
filtered we don't know but then also i
think a lot of his
fans um they did really feel a vacuum or
a void when he left because he left so
suddenly there was no clear evidence of
anything illegal per se
so a lot of them were like hey he
doesn't need to just [ __ ]
blast off the face of the earth because
he whipped his dick out lucy kate did
the same thing he's still here so why
did chris have to
well he's so gone so i think a lot of
people were quick to like want to
louisiana for like almost a year though
too like
or actually that's true but we forget
you know like we forget
like he's back and he's fine based i
mean not fine but he's back and he's
working so
i think it's easy to forget yeah
i guess if you're if you're a fan you
don't you don't see like
all the all the other stuff that they're
going through you know you're just like
wait come back yeah did he address the
reason why he disappeared
was it for like legal reasons or just
because he wants to get away or oh he
did
what did he say he said that he just
thought it was best to just be gone
right like he just felt like that's
that like he he came out with the
statement and he wanted the statement to
speak for itself and that's why they
just wanted that like this buffer time
to just like
let himself focus on how he needs to be
better
or like his own fix his relationship i'm
sure his girlfriend was like gonna leave
him i mean it probably got really bad so
he needed
and then how do you get on your podcast
the next week and like be funny when a
lot of your
comedy kind of oddly skirts around
like having this ego and like you're so
rich you know like
it doesn't make a dent it's like well
your your reputation has a huge [ __ ]
dent now
yeah i don't think it would have been
the right move to just continue
as normal after all that no i i think
that he did the right thing in that
regard to like take some time and
reflect but
yeah um yeah i think everyone has their
own
line all right it's really yeah it's
really just
a philosophical question at that point
it's pretty crazy i mean since i didn't
see any actual illegal behavior i don't
feel like his career should be
completely tanked
although morally i disagree with a lot
of his behavior so it's gonna be hard
for me to like
jump right back into being a fan and
that's kind of where i'm at on and i'm
like
i don't know if they're if the behavior
is stopped then that's
good right yeah i'm not a fan of or i
was never like a fan of his
hard for me to comment um but i am a fan
of eminem i don't know if you guys know
that yeah and
i know he's gotten accused of a lot of
things over the years i've been a fan
for over i mean listen to his lyrics he
talks about like [ __ ]
beating women and yeah
it's like you know when you're like you
have so much passion in your
relationship you're like you love them
but you hate them so much because you
love them so much and yeah you just want
to [ __ ] murder them yeah so
he got it out through art hopefully but
anyway watch we find out he has like a
basement full of
[ __ ] dead women no jessica sorry oh
don't ruin him
sorry sorry but yeah like he's gotten
he's gone through a lot of scandals he
got you know banned from mtv he was it
was a lot of stuff but
um i think like as a fan i have
like seen seen him grow and evolve and
like
he's apologized for certain things and i
you give him a pass as a tortured
artist yeah and just someone that was an
outcast and was like
beat on like all through his childhood
and i mean he went through a lot his mom
yeah and so um so yeah like i kind of
see all that and i'll give i'll weigh
all of these things but i know tons of
people like that
in our social circle that will not
ever be a fan or just like he's
misogynistic he's homophobic he's like
all these things
very problematic to be honest right and
so like as a fan i'm like no
i don't think so but yeah um if you're
an outsider or you just have like
these these facts that you're just these
these things that you're just seeing on
the surface i think it's easier to make
a judgment and be like oh what a
gross person right yeah so i think it's
all up to
how much you want to delve into knowing
that person and how much benefit of the
doubt you want to give and
where you are as a fan yeah how much
humanity you allow people to have that
also includes the dark side of humanity
so i think he's been very self-aware and
open with all of his mistakes and i
think that
at the end of the day yeah yeah and at
the end of the day
being a fan of anybody when they're
willing to like open up admit their
mistakes and like
move on and like evolve and grow like
oh
[Laughter]
that's a 30 year old realization gina
20 anyways thanks for watching our
episode y'all uh i learned something new
today
it wasn't any of this that's just
literally about marshall
anyways um yes uh subscribe to our show
if you enjoyed this conversation um if
you really want to support the show the
best way is to visit one of our sponsors
because they're the ones that keep this
show running
and give us five stars on itunes itunes
yeah rate us comment any sort of uh
interaction with the show whether it's
just
clicking on it and letting it run who
[ __ ] share with your friends share
with your friends
or talk [ __ ] in the comments i'll talk
[ __ ] back and we can go back and forth
and get a ton of comments
yeah say that i'm so boring in bed and
i'll to write back and i'll say well you
sound like a rapist so
yeah let's have a conversation
let's do it anyways thank you guys for
coming we'll see you next week bye